Welcome back. We are joined today by
Professor Jang who uses historical
patterns and game theory to predict the
direction of geopolitics. And uh
professor Jang is famous for many things
among some predicting the return of
Trump and also uh the war against Iran
now a second war that is. U so thank you
for coming back on the program.
>> Thanks Glen.
Um how how do you make sense of this war
though uh against Iran? I mean how how
do you measure how this war is
developing in terms of uh where the
successes or failures are
>> right? Um so first of all Trump has
failed to articulate a purpose and a
strategy for this war. Um at first it
was about nuclear enra uh uranium
enrichment in Iran uh and the fear that
Iran would develop a nuclear weapon. In
fact uh in Trump's state of the of the
union address um he said that he would
never allow Iran to develop a nuclear
weapon and uh both chambers of congress
that both the Democrats and Republicans
rose to cheer and applaud. It was really
the first time that Congress
demonstrated any unity during that
speech. It was a extremely uh political
uh speech.
Um but the problem with that is that um
the Omani foreign minister a few hours
before the Americans and Israeli struck
tan told um us that the Iranians had
already agreed to zero uranian
enrichment even for civilian purposes.
Um so the idea that um Trump needs to
prevent a nuclear weapon um that doesn't
hold. Is this a pretext? And they tried
different many different excuses. And
then finally, Rubio said this. Rubio
basically said, look, we had to attack
because Israel was going to attack
first. And then the Iranians would
retaliate against both the Israelis and
us. So to defend ourselves, we had to
preempt Israel and attack first. Okay.
So they're struggling for a narrative.
They're struggling to explain to the
American people um why this is
happening. They're also struggling to
contain a fallout because um after the
Americans and Israeli struck Iranians,
the Iranians start to bombard US bases
in uh the GCC and they close off the
humus and this is doing tremendous
damage to the global economy. So oil
right now it's um approaching $120 a
barrel, $110 a barrel, I'm not quite
sure. Okay, but this is double from a
week ago. And remember that the servus
delivers most of this oil to the Asian
economies of Pakistan, India, uh China,
South Korea and Japan. Japan relies on
75% of its oil from the sort of hummus.
So in about 7 8 months, Prime Minister
Takayachi has informed her cabinet that
uh Japan will be out of oil. Um and
Japan is you know a a a manufacturing
powerhouse. So
um this war has been a disaster and even
today Trump has failed to articulate why
the Americans are doing this, what the
purpose is and what the um offramp is.
And what we're seeing day by day is
pretty rapid escalation. In fact, I
think sec the second day or the third
day into this war, there were rumors of
ground troops. Uh yesterday, there's
rumors that the 82nd Airborne Division
uh of of the American army was uh given
deployment orders, meaning that meaning
it is possible Americans will choose to
airrop
uh the soldiers into the middle of Iran.
For what purpose? We don't know. There's
talk of the Americans seizing Car
Island, which is the oil depart of of
Iran, uh, and which accounts for 90% of
Iranian uh, oil exports. Um, there's
talk of the Americans uh, funding
proxies. Um, there's talk of using
tactical nuclear weapons. There's talk
of a national draft to find 500,000
soldiers for ground invasion of Iran.
So, this war is completely out of
control. And it is complete unclear what
the Americans hope to accomplish with
this war.
>> Yeah, the narrative I think was very
poorly planned, even worse than the war
has been planned because it began as you
said with nuclear weapons, then moved
over to ballistic missiles. Then as
apparently they wanted to help
protesters, then it was about the oil
that they should be taken out of the
hands of Iranians. Then Trump mentioned
Iran might take over the Middle East
unless um you know so we had to go in
and as you said the Israel thing was
interesting because if the argument is
that Israel will attack Iran then Iran
will retaliate against Israel against
Israel and the United States. So they
had to go in first then they're
essentially admitting that they're
fighting Israel's war but they can't say
that either. So, so the you the ability
to find that narrative is uh was kind of
poor compared to other wars. Other
usually have one narrative all the media
they they organize around it and
everyone obediently repeats the same
talking points. It's hasn't been done
well. But this is a war of attrition
though uh to a large extent that is both
sides seeking well both there's many all
all sides seeking to exhaust each other
but this is in terms of weapons
ammunition um but it's also spilling
into energy and yeah water if you will
or just general economics how how do you
see who would exhaust whom first
>> right so I think Iran is trying to fight
a war of attrition where it is putting
pressure
um on the global economy on the GCC
nations because Iran believes that uh
the GCC nations especially Saudi Arabia
uh Qatar and UAE can apply pressure on
Trump to end this war as quickly as
possible uh by closing off the Humus uh
Iran is trying to pressure the Southeast
Asian economies of China, Japan and
South Korea to press apply pressure on
Trump to end this war as soon as
possible. So the Iranians are fighting a
war of attrition. Unfortunately, the
Americans are fighting a war of
destruction. So even though they haven't
said the purpose, it is clear from what
is happening on the ground that the
Americans and the Israelis are intent
aren't complete and utter destruction of
the government's government's capacity
to deliver basic services to its people.
What I mean by that is that uh they
yesterday struck a dissalination plant
in Iran. Um it and you know so you're
denying fresh water to the civilian
population. That is a war crime. Um then
the Americans struck uh oil facilities
in Tran. Uh these are these are civilian
oil facilities so that uh citizens in
Tran can drive their cars. And if you
look at footage from Tran, it is the
apocalypse. It there's acid rain. uh the
entire uh the entire sky is black and
these people have to grieve that ear. So
they're they will develop cancer,
they'll have birth defects, uh it's
almost like chemical warfare. Um so if
you are just saying this a war of
attrition, um that makes no sense. A war
of attrition means when you embargo Iran
economically, why are you targeting
civilians? You know, in the first of the
war, a tomahawk tomahawk missile hit a
school in southern Iran and killed about
170 school girls. These are this is an
elementary school. 170 school girls were
killed in that. Um and and um this war,
the way it's being constructed, the way
it's being fought, seems to me that the
Americans are first and foremost focused
on the destruction of Iran as opposed to
uh regime change.
>> Yeah. Well, I guess that's a good
description that Iran is fighting a war
of attrition. So Taioon be on their side
while the US is well seeking to destroy
the country uh with its yeah 90 million
people inside. So uh this is quite
problematic but the Iranians of course
is limited what they can do to to the
United States. they can of course hit
their bases and um
but uh but it seems that Iran is
obviously prioritizing uh going after
the Gulf States because that's a good
way of uh creating some pain for the
USled alliance. How vulnerable do you
see them being here though?
Yeah. So, the Gulf States are the great
vulnerability of the American Empire
because Israel um it has an esquetology.
Uh unfortunately, religiously zealots
have taken over the state of Israel. So,
they're perfectly okay to die for what
they believe in. And um they can live in
bomb shelters for years and years.
That's how strong their faith is. Um and
Israel was designed as an extremely
resilient, extremely creative society.
So, uh, Israel will emerge from this war
intact and probably even stronger. The
but the Gulf States are different. The
Gulf States are basically mirages. Um,
these 50 years ago, these were just
deserts, right? They um and for most of
human history, the the Arabian Peninsula
was not that inhabited because it didn't
have access to fresh water. it didn't
have much agricultural um output and so
it cannot sustain um um a large
population and most were desert nomads
engaged in trade. But Pax Americana uh
changed all that because Pax Americana
could could needed oil to fund its
empire and it could offer protection to
the Gulf States. So they um they develop
really rapidly. So cities where maybe
tens of thousands of people before now
are in the millions. And one striking
example is Dubai. Uh you know you go to
Dubai, it's just skyscraper after
skyscraper. It is a very glitzy city and
it it's trying to be the financial
capital of um the Middle East and there
are thousands of extremely wealthy
individuals who've transferred their
savings to Dubai because they believe
that uh it's safe, it's comfortable,
lots of good Michelin restaurants, lots
of good five-star hotels and are not
taxed. Um but this image of Dubai as a
financial hub is now shattered by this
war and they'll never recover from this.
In fact uh we're already hearing rumors
of ver of of of millionaires just
fleeing with with their wealth. Now
they're going to Singapore. Now they're
going to um uh Southeast Asia. A bigger
problem is this. A bigger problem is
that because the S of Hum is closed,
their oil economies have collapsed. they
can no longer sell the oil and they shut
down their their oil production
facilities. What people don't recognize
is that uh the sham moose takes GCC oil
to to Asia but then it brings back food.
Uh the GCC um imports 80 80 to 90% of
its food supply. So Dubai was the rumor
is Dubai will run out of food in about a
week's time. Um then there's the issue
of fresh water where the greatest
vulnerability is actually desalination
plants. So the GCC nations um
desalination plants provide about 6% of
all their water needs and so if these
dissalination plants are destroyed then
they run out of water in one or two
weeks and this means the entire
destruction of the uh GCC now now I mean
destruation
plants will be the nuclear option for
Iran and so I don't think they would use
it very lightly um but Um there's really
no coming back from what's happening. I
mean for the longest time the GCC had a
reputation for being safe uh for being
extremely wealthy and now that mirage
that illusion has been shattered and
once the illusion is shattered you can't
ever uh resurrect it again.
No, I very much agree. Well, the Gulf
States not just um are not just
dependent on energy but the finance the
real estate market which is propped up
by all the experts. But what you're also
describing though is um that is the this
small monarchies selling the oils in in
dollar and the US in return offering
protection. This was also the petro
dollar system that uh replaced Breton
Woods once they closed the gold window.
So how what do you see being the
possible consequences for the global
economy?
>> Right. So what Iran wants to do is
basically kick the US out of the Middle
East for a lot of reasons and the main
advantage is that once the US leaves
Iran will be able to control the ship of
Humus. Therefore, it will control trade
access for the entire world and that um
and and so the Gulf states will bas
basically become client states of the
Iranians rather than Americans and that
oil money now will be able to finance uh
the rebuilding of Iran. So, so that's
the um end goal or the endgame for the
Iranians. The problem with empire is the
hubris. And so another way of saying
this is the empire would rather destroy
the world than surrender its power.
Right? So the idea that the Americans
will just leave the Middle East
peacefully is this wishful thinking.
Everyone's saying that you know this war
can only lead to the defeat of America.
So America should just admit defeat
right now and then go home and let
Israel and Iran settle whatever problems
that they have. like like the Middle
East is not America's problem. But
again, the problem is that America is
addicted to the petro dollar. Leaving
the Middle East would destroy the petro
dollar. And if the petro dollar is
destroyed, it would collapse the
American economy as well. So America has
$40 trillion in debt. Uh and this debt
is a is a Ponzi scheme. Like the
American economy is um is sustained by a
Ponzi scheme. And so the Gulf States,
what they do is they sell the oil, get
petro dollars, and then they recycle it
back into the American economy mainly by
investing into AI uh into data centers,
which is now um uh the main engine of
growth for the American economy. So the
Gulf States were to stop investing in
America. The AI financial bubble would
burst and with it the entire American
economy. America would suffer a much
greater depression than the 1930s.
That's how dire the situation is for
America right now.
But the United States though they must
have known that this would be a
disaster. I mean they many of the top
military people in the United States
warned in advance that uh they they
would have limited weapons. they would
have a limited ability to go on for too
long, which of course could explain why
they instead going for burning down Iran
if if they can't if time is essentially
on Iran's side. But uh but there's been
war games in the past where they show
that they they couldn't pull this off. I
mean, you had god knows how many
American presidents who wanted to attack
Iran. Uh but they always knew that yeah,
that's not a good idea. Uh so how how
how do you make sense of this? cuz that
was my one when when they were building
up to this war, sending more and more um
military hardware to the region. My main
reason for thinking this might not
happen was uh it would simply be too
crazy. The the likelihood of success,
the amount of things that could go
wrong. I mean, it just indicated that
this they can't possibly go down this
path. So So why I guess why why did they
they do have informed people in the
United States? I you know, we know. So,
how do you make sense of this?
>> Right. So, again, you I agree with you
in that this war doesn't make any sense.
It's not rational and everyone everyone
knows that America is going to lose this
war. The problem is that when empires
are in decline, this is just the way
they behave. And um there's just the
historical record, it's pretty
overwhelming in that when empires u
decline, they lash out against the
world. They start these stupid wars.
They can't possibly win. They overextend
themselves and the collapse is terrible
for the world. And America very much is
an empire in decline. Look at things
such as the collapse of the family. Look
at things uh such as the um collapse of
the currency. Currency debasement in in
America is just a tremendous problem.
The US dollar is no longer worth as much
as it was like uh like 10 years ago. Um
the political polarization America um
Congress just cannot function properly.
The president has so much power nowadays
because congress has basically decided
to just not do anything to avoid any
political responsibility and so it's
destroying the checks and balance
systems of the US constitution. Um the
economic depression in America is great.
Young people feel as though there's
absolutely no hope in the world. They're
refusing to have uh families. They're
refusing to invest in the future. They
gamble all the time. And so America is
really the end of empire at this point.
And so what they do is they go and start
wars in order to distract people's
people people's attentions in order to
prove to the world that they still have
it uh to, you know, they're still the
bully in a playground and they can still
beat up every other kid even though
they're old and they're and they're weak
and they're handicapped. Um and so you
know we're talking about Iran, but like
look at what was happening before Iran,
right? Trump um kidnapped the president
of of uh Venezuela uh which went which
went against international law. Trump uh
deployed his navy in the Caribbean and
started to bomb drug boats uh which is
again against international law. Um
Trump was threatening to annex
Greenland. He was threatening to uh
invade Canada. Um he was threatening to
attack Mexico. Right now he's embargoing
Cuba. And people people don't even
recognize this is happening because
there's so much going on in the world.
But Cuba was dependent on Venezuela oil.
That was its energy supply. And now that
Venezuela uh has fallen to the
Americans, um the Americans have
embargoled Cuba. And so now people don't
have access to electricity and they're
actually people are starving in Cuba. Um
so this is an empire in decline. It just
lashes out against the world. It attacks
everyone. Um and Iran is just the um
most current iteration of this anger and
this hubris. But this hubris made the
Americans underestimate the capacity of
Iran. They went in thinking that once
they decapitate the regime, then the
government would fall. And what they
what the Americans didn't recognize was
the resilience and resolve of the uh
Iranian people.
Well, about this imperial decline, it it
reminds me of something that Emanuel
Todd, the the French scholar, argued
because uh well, again, he predicted the
collapse of the Soviet Union already in
the '7s by looking at these different
social variables, but he also predicted
the US empire was heading towards uh
well, a similar fate already in the in
the early 2000s. and he described
essentially what you did this uh strange
he called it micro militarism this uh
this yeah brutal use of military force
uh in an effort to show power when it's
obviously draining so it it is an
interesting development but you you
mentioned that the Americans are losing
as if it's a given how how do you why do
you assess this is this the mainly the
focus on on the military hardware at
their disposal or is Is it the lack of a
clear objective? Um or I guess regime
change will be very hard without the
ground troops,
>> right? Um so America right now has
several disadvantages. Um the first
major disadvantage is the lack of
political will and that just means the
lack of a of a strategy, the lack of a
purpose. Uh it cannot unify the American
people um in order to make the sacrifice
necessary to win this war. In fact, most
Americans are against this war. Right
before the war started, uh 70 70 to 80%
Americans voice their disapproval of a
possible war with Iran. Um usually when
a war starts, uh people rally behind the
flag, but not in this case. Most
Americans are still against the war. So
the first issue is the lack of political
will. But if you look at the Iranians,
they believe that this is a struggle
over of life and death. So they set
aside the political differences and
they've committed to winning this war.
Okay. So that's the first um factor
political will. The second factor is
this manufacturing capacity. So these
past um 30 40 years America went from a
manufacturingbased economy to a
financialbased economy and they export
their manufacturing capacity to China.
Now when you fight a war, what really
matters is your uh capacity to produce
ammunition to replenish your um your
munitions uh logistics and America
doesn't have manufacturing capacity to
fight a long war. Um in fact what's
happening already is that America is
cannibalizing munitions from other parts
of the world. So South So um they are
now uh transferring uh munitions from
South Korea over to uh the Middle East
which is stupid to do because now you've
you've basically um opened more flanks
open more vulnerabilities throughout the
world. Uh so manufacturing capacity is a
very important factor. On the other
hand, Iran uses drones and ballistic
missiles. And we know that uh Iran is
able to manufacture about 500 drones a
day. And quite honestly, you you only
need to like have 10 drones hit their
targets in the Middle East uh every
single day in order for the GCC to cry
uncle, right? So manufacturing capacity
is a very important factor as well. And
um the third um factor is that America
is hamstring by a lot of political
considerations. So because they lack
political will, they do not want to take
too many casualties. Right? So Trump has
said that six Americans have died in
this war so far. There's absolutely no
way this is true. Um we are we are
having hearing rumors that there are a
lot of casualties being flown to Germany
to try to disguise a fact that uh the
middle in the Middle East u many
Americans are are are dying. Uh but this
tells us that America has actually no
appetite uh to sustain any casualties.
If you refuse to have any casualties,
how are you going to fight a war? Right?
On the other hand, the Iranians um are
very esqueological. Um they are very
religious. They are Shia Muslim and
they're not afraid to die. Um in fact
they believe it is the highest honor to
marty yourself for the higher good and u
and the clear example of this is the
Ayatollah Kamayat who was killed in the
first day of strikes and you know he
could have gone to Moscow and he could
have hid his bunker but instead he chose
to go go to his office and carry on with
his life because he's 86 years old and
he does not want to die afraid of
Americans and so he set the example that
is galvanizing ing the Iranian people.
Just look at some social media footage
from Iran. The Iranian people are now
extremely uh energetic, extremely
galvanized and they will fight this war
to the bitter end.
>> Yeah. Know I was in Tran last year and I
was also a bit um well that's one thing
that really stood out the
the culture of martyrdom. the way they
would put the martyrs pictures on the
walls at many places. The it this is um
you know an important variable beyond
the material variables if you want to
assess how a country would actually
fight and uh the whole idea of you know
killing Kamini and now everything will
fall into place. I mean his son has
taken over now and uh it has to be
pointed out that the Americans killed
his father, his mother, they killed his
wife, they killed his sister and they
killed his son. I mean the idea as Trump
said well we we will pick the next guy
and uh you know he will have to be
acceptable to us. He has to be more
favorable to America and accommodating
and uh more moderate.
It it doesn't make any sense how how can
you you know burn down the country and
uh again just if you look at a new
leader slaughter his whole family and
then assume that they will just fall in
line. If you look at the culture in Iran
again the martyrdom culture which is
strong you know you can say among
Shiites in general this was always crazy
but uh for somehow
this seem to have been the assumption.
Um, but how do you see though the
possibility of this war spreading?
Because they of course they're attacking
US bases which you know covers a lot of
country. So you have US proxies being
used such as Kurds which could then
trigger a civil war in a country of 90
million people. There's now um I mean
the American and British media
especially they're up in arms that
Russia is giving intelligence to Iran to
try to you know make Trump push harder
against Russia in Ukraine. Even though
this, you know, yeah, also a dangerous
path. I'm not sure if what to what
extent China would get get involved. I
mean, do you see a pathway here from it
being
coming a proper regional war or or a
world war? How do you see this?
>> Well, first of all, I don't think
there's an off ramp for this war. I
think it's very hard to de deescalate.
Um the idea that the Americans will just
give up their uh petro dollar and the
American bases and just go home is just
absurd. That is not how empires behave.
Also, Israel because it wants to achieve
the greater Israel project is heavily
invested in creating a regional
conflration to create as much havoc as
possible so that that they uh could
destroy the region and then be the only
one left standing. Okay. And so what
Israel wants to do is drag everyone into
the war including Turkey, including
Saudi Arabia, uh including um uh like
basically the entire Middle East. And so
um during the first couple of days,
there was reporting that an Iranian
drone had struck a Saudi Aramico oil
facility. And so Aramco closed down all
it energy production. But then later
reporting came out uh to reveal that
actually the drone came from Lebanon. So
it didn't come from the east east, it
came from the west which meant Israel.
Toro Carlson on his TV show uh sorry on
on his show said that he had received
information from the Qataris that they
they had arrested two MSAD agents and
they suspected these MSAD agents of
trying to sabotage
um the uh Qatar or facilities in order
to create a false flag. So the Israelis
are heavily invested in trying to create
as much conflict between the GCC and
Iran as possible. And now there's talk
of uh Turkey coming in as as well. Um
recently there was a drone attack from
Iran against Azaran and Azar Bzan was
very angry about this and even fought
the possibility of sending in ground
troops against Iran. But then it was
later discovered that this was probably
a false flag um of of the Israelis. So
the Israelis are in are heavily
interested in spreading this war as far
as possible and creating as much
destruction as possible and they want
this war to continue for as long as
possible because they have nuclear
weapons. So Iranians the Iranians are
not going to hit them too hard. Uh the
Iranians are going to hit the GCC much
harder. And so it's just for the Iranian
for the Israelis they just have to
endure, right? Right? It's a war of
attrition and then once Saudi Arabia is
destroyed, once a GCS is destroyed, then
Israel will be the only power left
standing. Okay? So that so that is
Israel's intention. Other nations will
eventually have to be drawn in as well.
So one wild card is Pakistan. So during
the 12-day war, Pakistan um uh supported
Iran.
But after that, a few months after that,
Saudi Arabia signed a mutual defense
path with Pakistan.
So if Saudi Arabia is attacked, Pakistan
must come to its aid. And we know that
Pakistan has nuclear weapons. So it is
very likely that at some point Saudi
Arabia will join this war on behalf of
the Americans. Uh because the animosity
between Saudi Arabia and Iran go way
back. Uh Iran is a theocracy. Saudi
Arabia is a monarchy and they see each
other as her as as heretical, okay, as
against uh um Islam. The Iranians hate
Saudi Arabia because Saudi Arabia is the
home of Mecca and Medina, the two
holiest sites in the Islamic world. At
the same time, they host a lot of
American soldiers. These are infidels in
the eyes of Iranians. And so, the
Iranians are heavily interested in
trying to topple the Saudi regime. and
um they're going to apply uh pressure to
cause uprisings throughout the the GGC.
And I believe that at some point the
Saudi uh government will decide to enter
this war. And if they enter this war,
then Pakistan is obligated to enter this
war as well. If the Americans were to
launch a ground invasion, it would make
sense to attack from multiple vectors.
And one vector would be from Pakistan.
Another vector of course would be from
Iraq. The last vector would be from uh
Azar Bjan. They would also try to cease
the situ as soon as possible in order to
maintain uh global trade. Um so that in
the short term so in the short term we
can expect the entire Middle East to be
engulfed in this war at um at some
point. In the long term eventually the
Southeast Asian economies will have to
intervene. So South Korea and Japan are
extremely reliant on um oil from the
strip of hummus. In fact, they would
basically starve to death if it were not
from this oil from uh the strip of
Humus. But there's a wild card and
that's North Korea. So, if you're in
North Korea and you are analyzing the
situation, you recognize that now is the
perfect opportunity to threaten South
Korea because Americans are distracted
in uh the Middle East and the South
Koreans don't have access to the oil
they need to protect themselves against
the North Koreans. So just threaten
South Korea and then the Americans are
forced to direct their attention back to
Southeast Asia and Japan is forced to
come into this conflict as as well. And
the North Koreans aren't doing this to
start to start a war. That would be
suicidal. They're doing this to extort
as much as possible from South Korea and
Japan. Um and so I expect that to happen
as well. the Western Hemisphere will not
be quiet this time because while this is
happening, Trump is still intent on
toppling the Cuban government. Okay, so
it's possible two weeks from now um
while this war is still raging, Trump
attacks Cuba or Mexico or Colombia. It
is complete insanity. Um but this is
again unfortunately this is the way an
empire behaves as it declines.
So uh yeah, what you're describing is uh
more or less a suicide or death of
empire at least. Uh but um after this
war is over, of course there's no going
back to the way things were. So how do
you see this um the wider change to the
Middle East as a region?
>> Well, I think the GCC is done for. Um I
don't think it's possible to come back
from what's happening. Um and after this
war is done, I think that Israel emerges
as a dominant power in um the Middle
East. It achieves the greater Israel
project and um the Iranians will not
lose this war. They will maintain their
sovereignty, but this war is going to
destroy a lot of their infrastructure
and they'll have to rebuild.
Fortunately, they will be able to
control the shoo and so they'll have um
the financing necessary to rebuild their
nation. And I think that um after this
war the Iranians will actually come out
much stronger uh than before. Uh they
will um be uh they will control the
Hummus. Uh they will have a more um
vibrant coherent national identity and
uh they will will have upgraded a lot of
their military capacity. So um maybe
after this war they're destroyed but
they'll rebuild and they'll come out
much stronger and this will lead to in
the long term region re regional
conflict between Iran and Israel and in
esquetology in uh Islamic and in um
Jewish and in Christian esquetology this
conflict between Iran and Israel and
this is a long-term thing right but it
is often referred to as the war of Gog
and Mog when the entire world attacks um
Israel. Okay. So um but before that
happens, Israel will achieve the greater
Israel project and it would create
something called PAX Judeica. So imagine
that the center of gravity um basically
uh transfers from Washington DC to
Jerusalem. Why? Because at this point in
history uh Israel
uh it controls all global trade. It's
it's already built the Bengurian canal
which cuts through uh Gaza and replaces
the the Suez Canal. Um it is the techn
technological and financial center of
the Middle East because the GCC has been
destroyed and so and so whatever oil
money there is is put invested into uh
Israel. you know um the Indian prime
prime minister Modi visited Netanyahu
before the war struck out before the war
began and it was a very pleasant meeting
and the reason why is that in order to
build Paka Israel need to import
millions and millions of cheap laborers
and India is the best source of cheap
laborers for for Israel. Um so I think
that that is what they have in mind. you
know a lot of technological companies in
United States, Google, uh, Nvidia,
Oracle, they are they will probably move
to Jerusalem and help build the
technological center of the world,
create an u a an AI surveillance state.
So these past few decades um they create
this surveillance model in Gaza and then
they'll just scale it out to include the
entire Middle East. Um, so that's what I
see happening in the short in the short
term. this war will be devastating. In
the midterm, Israel will achieve the
greater Israel project and create
Pakida. And long term, um, Israel will
face the world in in in a global
conflict.
But to what extent would Israel be in a
position or to to project this kind of
power? Because after this war, there
would be a seemingly a very diminished
US presence in at least ability to
project power in the Middle East. Uh
Turkey is also growing more concerned uh
about Israel. Uh indeed the Israelis
also have a very tough rhetoric about
Turkey and especially Erdogan. And with
the war as well, the the amount of
destruction that will be levied against
the Israelis, the economic
complications, the demographic problems
as many settlers might be simply
leaving. Um I mean it's not a big
country. What is this like 8 million
people now? 78. Uh how how how would
they be able to I guess sustain
themselves in this region once all of
these things begin to kick in.
>> Also political instability one could put
add to the list I guess. Yeah.
>> Yeah. So I think um let's talk political
instability because Israel is notorious
for political divisions, right? It's
almost impossible to get people to agree
on anything. Israelis argue all the
time. But this war is going to have a
traumatic traumatic effect on Israeli
society. Uh the democracy is going to
have to give way to a theocracy. Um the
religious zealots are going to gain
greater control over Israeli society and
what is whatever is left of an open
cosmopolitan democratic society will
wither away. Basically, Jerusalem will
replace Tel Aviv as the heart and center
of Israeli society. Um, so, uh, that's
point one. Point two is that people
severely underestimate Israel because it
is a small, uh, nation in a desert with
very few resources. But the real wealth
of Israel is a Jewish diaspora spread
all around the world. Um, they are
extremely well educated. their $10 is
really savvy and they are um um and and
um they are extremely united like like
they believe in the greater greater
Israel project. So it's possible for
Israel to draw on basically unlimited
financing on the most advanced
technology on um on political support
from all over the Jewish uh diaspora.
Um, and I think that once this war is
over, Israel will have no pure
competitor in the Middle East, meaning
that Saudi Arabia Saudi Saudi Arabia
will probably be destroyed and Turkey
will be severely weakened in the
process. I'll be honest with you, I have
very little um hope for Turkey. Um, it
has suffered a great deal under EderN.
Um, if you go back and looked at how
Migrant came to power and how he
cemented power, um, I believe it was in
the 20 what year was it 2018? Uh, coup.
Um, and anyway, my my point is that
Turkey is an extremely corrupt and
oified society. That is a paper tiger.
And if Turkey were to enter this war,
you'd be surprised by how badly it it
does. So, so Israel in other words
doesn't have a regional competitor. Iran
will be a competitor in the future, but
that is in the future.
>> Yeah. No, I think um yeah know that the
the coup attempt in 2016, I think this
was very clear. Uh well, it's not the
first time they have this every now and
then that it the stability
um might be quite fragile. Uh but you
you kind of covered very well the Middle
East, how the US is impacted, how this
could spread to East Asia, uh Israel
could become a theocracy, Iran a even
more confident regional power. How about
Europe? Because we um you know are the
Americans uh liberated us from the
Nordstream pipeline by blowing it up.
European leaders recently congratulated
themselves for liberating themselves
from Russian energy and gas and oil,
sorry. And um now of course uh we're
also been cut off from uh energy from
the Middle East and uh all of this with
the backdrop of the United States uh
seeking to pivot away from Europe. So
how how does this debacle in the Middle
East with the war in Iran impact the
Europeans?
Well, it's I mean like the Europe Europe
is completely hopeless. It's a hopeless
situation. Um you know for the past 20
years it's America scooed over Europe.
So um these wars in the Middle East
created millions of refugees who then
went to Europe. Um, and I don't know
what the Europeans were thinking in
allowing these millions of refugees to
come into the society when they didn't
have the capacity to absorb these
millions of refugees. Right? So, Ed
Merkel, the chancellor of Germany,
famously said, "We can do it." No, you
can't. uh and time has shown that these
millions of refugees have put a
tremendous strain on the social cohesion
on the uh capacity of the state to
govern uh Europe. So there's tremendous
uh political fissures within uh Europe
at this point and so that's why you see
the rise of these right-wing parties
throughout Europe. Uh but the main
problem as you point out is the economy.
So Europe suffers from an aging
population. So the population itself is
not no longer as dynamic as it used to
be. Uh before the model, the German
model was very good. It was this, you
know, buy cheap
um Russian energy,
make uh really good German cars,
subcontract the labor to Poland, and
then sell extremely expensive German
cars to China. It was a great model for
Germany. But then when Trump came into
office, um the China market uh Germany
lost lost access to the China market.
And then when you have this war break
out, Germany was no longer buy cheap
Russian energy. And as you point out,
the Europeans then pivoted to uh the
Middle East, primarily Qatar. And now
Qatar has basically shut down all LNG
production. And so uh Europe is
completely screwed in the process.
Immacron has talked about sending an
aircraft carrier to the Middle East.
What's that going to do? I mean, send a
aircraft carrier so that the Iranians
can sink it with ballistic missile. I
mean, what's the point of that? Um, so
uh and and still at this time, the
Europeans are still talking about
drafting young men to go die in the
trenches of Ukraine in in 2029. So, the
Europeans, the European elite have their
head in the sand. They absolutely no
idea what's going on. They have
absolutely no solution to the multiple
crises that they face. And the Europe is
a dumpster fire. I hate to say this, but
it's a dumpster fire.
Well, it's hard to disagree with with
that assessment, but uh no, things are
going from bad to worse. I think the the
the reason why Europe went from this
immense optimism to now just crash uh
you know, you can say hubris and all
this, which is all correct. I think it
was the postcold world order though it
uh it became ideal for the Europeans
that is the United States were you know
declared a unipolar moment the the role
of the Europeans in this world was well
let's have a collective hedgeimonyy of
the political west standing on these two
legs of the US and the EU hoping that
Europe would be an equal partner to the
United States and not only would the
political west dominate the world but it
would be a force for good because
Not only would it prevent great power
rivalry but also by dominating the
liberal democratic west would be able to
and elevate the role of liberal
democratic values, humanitarian ideals.
So again it's um it's almost like a
civilizing mission that dominance is a
and sovereign inequality is a force for
good in the world. The world will thank
us for dominating. So this is the benign
hedgeimon. It's very appealing if you're
a politician and you say we dominate and
the world will love us for it. So now
that of course this is falling falling
apart. I guess a bit of a mirage like
the Gulf States were relying on uh it's
uh there's no no clarity what to do and
there's no political imagination because
they they outsourced all strategic
thinking to the US for the for 80 years
and now the US is essentially well
pulling out its knives for the
Europeans. They they've done this as you
said uh over the past 20 years but they
did it did it more covertly now they're
quite open about their contempt for
Europe. So no no I think Europe is done
but what does this mean for the wider
world order because this idea of a you
know the international distribution
being focused around US global primacy
legitimized then by liberal democratic
values. This world order the postcold
world order of liberal hedgemony is
gone. uh so the US is not dominant
anymore and liberal democratic values I
mean no one really thinks this is what
the western powers are that these are
their objectives in foreign policy it's
a thin ve which has been tossed away so
what is the new world order then from
your perspective what what will follow
this u
>> right so there will be three major
trends that follow from this okay the
first major trend is
de-industrialization
uh because you now have access to cheap
energy. So you need to make your economy
much more balanced before we have the
growth of urban centers which um engage
in the knowledge economy which engage in
AI in EV
um in solar panels right but all that
but all of that requires access to cheap
energy which is what the Middle East
provided but now that the Middle East is
going to be destroyed or be engulfed in
war for the next 10 20 years you have to
de-industrialize you have to focus more
on um self-sufficiency. Okay, so that's
the first trend, de-industrialization.
Second major trend is mercantalism.
Okay, and what I mean by that is that
the global order is dead. And so what
you need to do is basically focus on
local trade or creating your own supply
networks, spirits of influence. Okay.
And the third uh major trend which is
most troubling is remilitarization
because Pax Americana is dead. and tax
Judeica is not interested in protecting
you from big bad bullies. Okay? So it's
either you rearm as soon as possible and
defend yourself or you will be or you'll
be eaten alive by a wolf. Right? So I
think in um East Asia the the first
nation to recognize the changing world
order because has no choice in the
matter is Japan. I think that they
brought in partnersh because she
appealed to the young and she has the
charisma to galvanize the young to make
make this make the sacrifices necessary
in order to de-industrialize
remilitarize and create a
self-sufficient economic system. Um, so
I think that Japan will actually suffer
in the beginning, but they will actually
be in the forefront of global change and
nations that absolutely refuse to make
these three necessary changes will be
the most likely to suffer. And quite
honestly, I have very little hope for my
own country, which is China. I I think
that because of these changes uh Japan
will start to emerge as the local
hedgeimon while China is still stuck to
the old global order. Um but in a short
term what this means is that the United
States and China will have a repulse
month. Okay. So even this war has
started uh Trump will still visit
Beijing
uh March 31st at the end of this month
for a three-day state visit. And I think
that people will be surprised by how
friendly and productive this meeting
will be. And in fact actually this year
this there are scheduled three major
summits between China and the United
States. And so I think that both nations
are working towards a reproachment in
order to repair the global order. But
there's no saving the global order. It's
dying. And so if you omit this reality
and commit to revamping society, deind
industrializ sorry de-industrialization,
remilitarization
and moving towards a self-sufficient
economy, then you are much more likely
to weather the storm that is coming.
>> You say that China's stuck in the old
world order and one can see why. Um well
with 40 years of uh unprecedented u
prosperity and growth in human history
one can see why one would want to at all
cost keep this world going even though
it already went away. It's not that
unlike the Europeans though because then
you know the '9s you know was a rebirth
of Europe or you know thought together
with the US was the center of the world.
I remember having books at university
which were with the title why the 21st
century belongs to Europe. I mean this
was kind of the me mentality. I thought
that was also always a bit ridiculous.
But anyways, there was reason for
optimism it seemed. So that's why they
also cling on to a world order which is
dying which is why they're not able to
to adjust to the new world. One place
though where the there's a lot of
pressure to readjust to the new order is
Russia. that is um uh you know the
spokesperson Pescov he was he made a
comment now recently saying that we have
lost what uh well we have all lost what
we call international law so the system
is essentially dying if not dead and I
think what really shook them was the
decapitation strike on Iran because this
is you know the desperate act of a dying
empire and why wouldn't they do the same
towards Russia indeed they've been
attacking their nuclear deter current
very openly. I would say they there was
a I think this is likely that they tried
to assassinate Putin at Valdai with this
attack at least you know is a theory and
again why why wouldn't they go for a
decapitation strike against Russia this
is what many are thinking they look what
they did done to Iran there's no rules
so why then is Russia doing this slow
war of attrition and also they did this
at expense of their deterrent that is
they allow the Americans and the
Europeans
to openly, you know, launch missiles
deep into Russia. You can have a German
chancellor sitting on stage saying, "Oh,
yes, we imposed untold casualties on the
Russians." I mean, this there's so much
pressure now on the Kremlin to drop this
whatever they've done the past four
years. And why not do like the Iranians?
Time to, you know, bring some pain to
the Europeans because Europeans for the
past four years said, "Why should the
war be limited to Ukraine? Why not also
extend it to Russia?" Well, why
shouldn't the Russians bring it to
Europe? This is what I see as the
direction which is uh well terrifying
because uh this is um a you know recipe
for much larger war. I was wondering h
how do you see this the Russian
component here because you know they're
also one of the great powers
>> right so what so I look look I
personally think that of all the world
leaders
Vladimir Putin is the only one only one
of a grand strategy uh he's a very
capable leader and he sees the big
picture he he plays chess um and so what
he's waiting for is a US grasation of
Iran that's what he's waiting for
Because once the United States sends in
ground troops, then the United States is
all in. It can extrocate itself from the
situation. At any point, the United
States can stop this air campaign and
said, "You know what? We killed the
Aatollah. We destroyed uh the Iranian
nuclear threat. So, we're going to go
home, guys. Goodbye." Okay. But once the
United States sends in ground troops,
then it's locked in to this Iran
quagmire for 5 to 10 years, and there's
no escaping. It'll be like it it'll be
like another Vietnam, right? This gives
Putin and Russia the perfect opportunity
to move towards Odessa which is the real
goal and the end goal of this war in
Ukraine because once they have Odessa
then they have basically achieved all
their major military objectives and so
what's going to happen is the Europeans
will have no choice but to defend Odessa
to the last European and that's where
the next major conflict will be uh the
siege of of Odessa And if the siege of a
desert were to happen, the Europeans
would exhaust themselves defending
against the Russian attack. Um the
Russians have perfected drone artillery
warfare in the trenches of Ukraine. And
that's a perfect combination if you are
to uh besiege Odessa. And so the
Europeans, they may be fresh, but they
will be inexperienced.
And so they will make a lot of mistakes.
They will lose a lot of casualties. And
this war will eventually become so
unpopular back in Europe that this that
the population would revolt against the
governments. Okay? So remember this is a
time of nuclear war. So you can't
actually destroy each other's military.
What you what you can do is put so much
stress and pain on the political system
that the citizens ultimately rebel and
overthrow the the political system and
and impose a new system that is much
more friendly towards Russia. So that I
think is the grand plan that Putin has
and it's going to work.
>> Well, as uh I think it's the Chinese who
say it's uh we live in interesting
times. So thank you very much.
>> Huh.
>> It's much too interesting.
Well, thank you for taking the time and
um yeah, it's uh as as you began saying
this war against Iran, it's hard to
believe that they went through with this
given all the risks. But uh uh this is I
always make the point uh this is going
to be the the greatest catastrophe is
this illusion of escalation control. The
assumption that they can control all the
variables, decide how it ends, who's
allowed to participate, how they
contribute. I mean, this is really the
same as with the Russians in Ukraine.
The this assumption of escalation
control, this is what's going to kill us
effectively, though.
>> Well, I will say this. I made this
prediction two years ago the United
States will in would invade Iran. I've
been saying for two years consistently
that this would happen. The moment that
it happened, I was shocked and Bill
Wilder and I couldn't sleep because I
was like, why would they do this? So,
um, so yeah, I mean I I I sympathize
with what you're feeling.